How many Qurans are there? There's only
one. How many Qurans am I holding up?
Three of them. So, these are three
different Qurans? If it's If it's the
only one book that I know, and it's
three different copies.
>> This one is the Warsh, this one is
Qalun, the black one, and this one is
Hafs. You mean to tell me that these
three books are also one book?
>> Yeah, but that that's not the point
though.
So, you guys believe
in the Trinity, which is like God,
Jesus is the son of God, and then the
Holy Spirit, right? Yeah, yeah, the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit,
yep. Perfect, perfect. So, what confuses
me is like how is that
three, but not one? I mean, how is that
Yeah, yeah, how is that three, but not
one?
It's three persons and one God, so it's
three in one sense, one category, one in
another.
All right, so
cuz I like to keep it simple, bro, if
anything. Let's just say if God forbid,
like, you know, let's just say if
they've like Okay, let's just say if you
go when you if you go to heaven, God
willing,
and you like who are you going to see in
heaven?
Well,
the scripture says that we're going to
see the Father sitting on the throne.
Uh-huh.
>> We'll see the Lamb, Jesus Christ,
Uh-huh. and the Holy Spirit flowing from
their throne.
So, how many things are you looking at?
Three persons. One God, like I said.
Three in one category, personhood, one
in another category, essence, God,
nature.
So, that's not So, that's not like
you're not looking at three right there?
Do you like you're going to look at the
You're going to see the Father, and then
you're going to see Jesus, and then
>> Three three What? Hold on. Cuz you're
asking You're asking me again, so What
What did you understand from when I when
I said when I'm saying categories, I
said three in one category, and one in
another. What what What did you
understand from when I just what I just
said?
I mean, when I when I hear three
persons, well, I just I feel like it's
three people. And when you say persons,
are you talking about personality or
like what do you mean by persons?
Talking about rational agents. So, you
know, agents with the with mind, will,
emotion, rationale.
I don't know cuz like when I when I see
like, you know, when I see like in the
Bible like I don't mean to jump, but I'm
just saying like when I see in the Bible
like, you know, Jesus talking to the
Father
that just shows that the Father is not
the Son, but they are the
>> correct. That shows that there are That
shows they are distinct persons. Mhm.
You're absolutely right.
The Father's not the Son. They're three
distinct persons.
Yeah, I mean
cuz like for me like when you say as I
said like when you say you're going to
see the Father on the throne, then
you're going to see Jesus, which is the
lamb that you said, and then you're
going to see the Holy Spirit. For me
like that's For me that's three things
that you're looking at. So, how is that
You know what I'm saying? Like I don't
know. It's like
It's like basically seeing three beings
in front of me, you know?
You know, the persons and beings are two
different things. You're seeing one
being who exists as three persons.
Remember, these are two different
categories we're talking about. Do you
understand what I what I when I say two
different categories, you know what I
you know what I mean by that? Uh-uh.
So,
like It's like this. If I were to ask
you uh
how many numbers is the number three?
How many numbers is that?
The one.
Right, but it's three though.
No, but that's like a that's that's like
Isn't that like math concept though?
Like it's It's still one number. Yeah,
it's one number, but yet it's three.
How how is it both one and three at the
same time? But that's the thing. Like
how are we comparing the number three to
God? You know what I'm saying? Like
Well, that's I'm just We're just We're
just going over categories here. We're
just trying to break simple things down
so that we can understand the bigger
things. So, you you understand how
three
is also one at the same time, right?
Mhm. It's one number, yet with the value
of three.
So, it's one in one category, meaning
it's only one singular number. Yet, it's
three in its value. So, it's value.
Wait, hold on. Just I want to make sure
you understand this. Mhm. So, so you
have value is one category Mhm.
>> while
how many numbers it actually is or the
number of the number is another
category. It's one number with the value
of three. So, it's three in one at the
same time, just in different categories.
You understand? Okay. I can give you Can
I Can I give you a counter example if
you don't mind? Wait, did you Did you
understand this? Kind kind of, but but
I'm uh What did you not understand from
that? Cuz I feel like that was like Cuz
when you When When you said it like
that, I could say in my mind as well,
okay, three You're right, three is a
number is one singular number, but it
has a value of three, which that I
understand. But, the thing is, let's
just say if I put three apples in front
of you.
It's still the number three, but it's
three different apples.
Agreed. So, there's no different
category that we're talking about there.
Those are three apples.
>> [snorts]
>> But, so when we're talking about things
with when we're talking about things
with multiple categories Mhm. like what
we just talked about we're talking about
things that are
some They're something in one way and
they are another in another way. Can be
three in one way and one in another way.
So, when I'm talking about the God of
the Bible, he's three in one way. What
way? Personhood. Three persons. He's one
in another way. What way is he one?
Essence, nature, God. There's only one
nature.
Okay. Um can you give me another example
by using that same logic instead of wait
wait
>> I need to give you another example? Just
so I could see if like I understand it.
You know what I'm saying? That's what I
feel like you do. How do you How do you
What What's What What do you not
understand? These are two different
categories we're talking about. No, no,
cuz I just told you like, you know when
you gave me that example, okay, I'll
understand the person how they would
like I understand what you're trying to
say. Like I I'm trying to see cuz I'm
trying to see how you how you believing
in it. You know what I'm saying? But the
thing is for me
it's still in my mind if you put three
different apples or three different
fruits in front of me, that's still it's
a fruit, but it's three different
fruits. It's three literally it's three
of them.
So it's it's kind of that's the reason
why like I'm trying to say like it's
kind of like the same concept. You know
what I'm I don't know. But that's that's
what I think of
when when it's like that.
Okay.
So, let me ask you this.
How many Qurans are there?
There's only one.
How many Qurans am I holding up?
Let me ask you a question. Nope. I'm How
many Qurans am
>> There's three books in front of you.
There's three books, but the thing is
tell tell me one tell me one mosque in
the world that uses those three.
>> I just want to know how many Qurans am I
holding up. You're holding three books.
Are these Are these Qurans? For me, I
don't believe those are three different
Qurans. I I believe that there's only
one.
>> good.
You're You're You're about to get it.
Are Are these Qurans?
Yes.
How many Qurans am I holding?
Three of them.
So these are three different Qurans?
If it's If it's the only one book that I
know, and it's three different copies.
Well, no, cuz this is a This one is the
Warsh.
This one is Qalun, the black one, and
this one is Hafs. All right, so let me
ask you Let me ask you this. How many
How many How many
Like this is what I'm This is what I'm
cuz I'm going to say one more time. I
believe that there's one book, but if
there's versions, somebody could have
wrote that version. You know what I'm
saying? In my opinion, and I want to ask
you this question. What mosque in the
world uses those three books in the
mosque? Uh not all three, but you have
in Morocco, you go to the masjids in
Morocco, they use this one, the Warsh.
Um in Egypt, and like even in your
masjids use this one, the Hafs.
Um I'm not sure which which ones use the
Qalun as their main. I don't know if
they use the Qalun as their main one,
but it exists.
But yo, I'mma be honest. Like I have
Moroccan friends and I have Egyptian
friends. All of them say that it's only
one Quran. No.
Well, of course they all say that, but
they still identify
They're the the main one that they use
in Morocco is Warsh. And if you don't
mind me asking, where do you get that
information from?
Uh from your Islamic sources. So like
for example, if you if you look up in
Mhm. in Egypt Mhm. the Hafs Quran was
the one they standardized for Egypt.
That happened in 1924. You can look this
up right now if you want to.
Okay?
When you look up the main Quran they use
in like the schools in Morocco and for
learning and study it's the Warsh. Mhm.
It'll tell you.
So I'm I'm holding up Hafs, Qalun,
Warsh.
You You said these are all Qurans.
And you also said these are three.
Three Qurans, right? No, no, no. I don't
want you to change my words. I said that
they're three like those are three books
that you're holding, but it's the same
Quran. But if you're going to I don't
believe I don't believe in three
different versions as I said. So no no
no worries. Yes. I got you. So is this a
Quran?
>> [clears throat]
>> Huh? Is this a Quran?
From what you're holding right there,
yeah.
Okay. Is this a Quran?
Okay.
And this is a Quran? Okay. So what's So
what's Let me ask you, what's the
difference What's the difference So
what's
>> How many? Hold on. How many Qurans am I
holding? As I told you, three different
books, one Quran. That's what I'm trying
to explain to you. So it's So So these
So wait, hold on. You mean to tell me
that these three books are also one
book?
Yeah, but that Yeah, that's not the
point though.
It is [clears throat] the point cuz
you're just saying Cuz look, this is
what you said. These You're saying these
are all one even though they're three.
So they're three in one way
but they're also one in another. Is that
right? But that But let me ask you.
Wait, is is that correct? No, as I said,
if it's one cuz look, I don't Me
personally, I don't read that much
Arabic, but in my opinion cuz I see
everybody
>> brother. You don't You don't got to read
Arabic. You just to answer to answer
this simple concept.
>> Mhm. These are three in one way and one
in another. Is that right?
So what's your answer for the apple
cider that I gave you?
>> Is Is it a yes or no, man? Bro, I told
you it's three It's one Quran, but three
different like three books in Arabic.
>> So these are three and they are also one
in another way, correct?
>> you. If that was cuz I don't want to
interrupt you. My bad. If that was the
case, everybody would be reading one
book.
>> Brother, it's a simple It's a simple
answer. I'll I'll ask you again in a
very straightforward way. Okay.
These are three
Qurans that I'm holding,
yet it they are only one Quran in
another sense, correct?
When you say one Quran in one sense,
what do you mean?
I got to let you go, brother. No, but
I'm
Take care.
>> [snorts]
>> Islam.